Okay, the next question was about larger applications
where you inherently have to deal with more than one table.
Earlier in the course you mentioned that doing joins was a very bad idea
and could be very expensive.
How do you get around that when you inherently are dealing with difficult types of data.
That's another interesting question, and the answer isn't super simple.
In App Engine you can't do joins, but you can also store complicated objects
that have nest structures, so you can have lists, for example, as a property in your App Engine object.
You can actually get around a lot of the need for joins by using that sort of thing.
But let's say you're just using SQL and you want to scale it across many machines.
Joins are really tough, which means having these foreign relationships
in your database are really tough.
The way it was phrased in the question was basically like do we store data
in multiple places to to avoid multiple queries? The answer is sometimes yes.
Other times you do multiple queries.
What I usually do when I'm writing this sort of thing is I cache the bejesus out of all of my queries.
I try to structure all of my queries to have generally the same structure,
which is look up something by ID or by a few constraints.
For example, if we're loading Reddit's front page, I'll do a query for each of the Reddits
to get the top post in each Reddit, and then I'll merge them,
and that'll be cached.
>From them on, I'll just pull from that cache.
Then there's all these extra little properties that link can have per user.
Did you like it? Did you up vote it? Did you down vote it? Did you save it?
Did you submit it. All those things.
I'd probably do another query to a separate table to get all that information for that user
and then I would cache that so that in the future most of that stuff
is just bouncing off memcached.
On the first version of Reddit, we actually did a big join there and it became too slow.
The users table of all this information--uploads and downloads and all that stuff--
moved to its own machine, so we couldn't do joins easily anymore.
Yeah, it turned into multiple queries, sometimes storing extra little pieces of information
in different places, so it makes your writes more expensive and a little bit more complex,
but it makes your reads, while more numerous, simpler and easier to cache.
Because if you keep your queries to key value, those queries are very, very fast,
and they're also very easy to cache.
Just key to value. It mirrors what you're cache is doing.
It's actually a complicated question with a complicated answer.
What you just need to be thinking is what makes sense in that particular situation.
There is certainly a situation where the features is never going to be a big-scale,
and you can just put everything in one database and use joins and do it that way if you want.
You just need to kind of have in mind how big this is going to be
and how many of these decisions do I need to make right now
versus just getting it working.
I hope that helps.
There isn't an easy answer to that because every problem is a little bit different.
Do what works best. Do what works for now.
If you have to scale it later, good luck. Congratulations.